welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the book
of boba fett episode two from train trip
into lizard dripping this entire episode
was a glorious vision that i am gonna
break down shop by shop for all the
easter eggs and visual details that you
might have missed and thank you to baksu
for sponsoring this video more on them
later we open gliding up the crack path
leading to the palace of jabba the hutt
the same path threepio and r2 walked up
early on in return of the jedi but now
then exchange escorts that captured
assassin the gates creak open as we saw
when luke passed under them these gates
designed with team shapes that make it
look like you're entering into the giant
gaping maw of a beast now this assassin
is played by paul darnell a longtime
stunt performer who actually doubled for
timothy oliphant and the mandalorian
meanwhile the ghemorians are played by
colin hymes longtime stunt actor and
stunt driver and frank trigg veteran mma
fighter the assassin swears that boba
and hatis
is the general huti's insult roughly for
piss off or fu which are also standard
greetings in new york we actually first
heard this from a protocol droid of 3po
and cloud city and empire oh nice to see
a familiar face
how rude but we also heard a version of
this in the first episode of the
mandalorian
mango now at the time some fans thought
that they were changing the meaning of
this profanity to a general aggressive
greeting but if you listen closely that
guy did say achuta and now you can hear
this assassin really accentuate the e
matt berry voicing jabba's torture
droid8d8 returns he is of the order of
the night wind the nightwind is a new
group previously unheard of in star wars
but there was a pirate freighter named
the nightwind in the 90s role-playing
game but then phoenix says perhaps he
fears the rancor
yes it is a rancor head carving on that
throne where fennick hits that switch
and four more ranker carvings are on the
base of the throne as it rolls forward
for a better view as it did with jabba
but remember jabba had a different
button on his arm rest that he pushed so
these new armrests must have been
installed by bigfortuna the assassin
falls through the same trap door that
luke does rolling down into the dungeon
and i love how the moment she said
rancor those gamoreans cleared the hell
out of the way now on the other side of
the rancor pit you can see that gate
with the inner door raised and that red
and green lit panel just as luke left it
in return the jedi but there is no
rancor here since of course luke killed
the rancor with a heavier gate crashing
down on its head but no backup rancor
despite finnick mentioning a menagerie
and despite mochi being recovered by
bigfoot tuna in bad batch all we get is
a little rodent just like the ones
threepio saw in jabba's dungeon so as
boba leads the assassin back into town
to face the mayor they're glared at by a
number of transnotions despite that
trandocion leaders tribute last episode
clearly this family did not expect boba
to survive the day and then after being
given some uh nonverbal ichu does by the
clerk and then by pasquezi returning as
a toilet major domo they meet the mass
espe mayor mach chaise an ethorian race
voiced by series director robert
rodriguez he's a member of the order of
the night wind as he talks through his
neck orifices those sounds are received
by a mouthpiece that translated through
the apparatus that rest atop his head
just let the puppeteering here we
actually first saw an athorian in the
cantina in the 1977 star wars and here
it looks like the designers give mike
chaise more wrinkles and fuzzy whiskers
puffier eyes all to give them a more
aged look mock chaise and his guards all
wear a matching golden medallion with
the same signet it does bear a bit of
resemblance to the signet of the hutt
clan but it's not exact maybe it's
upside down it's also a bit like the
tattoo on the male hut's chin either way
this mare is still more loyal to the
huts than to this assumed interim boss
and he advises running a family is more
complicated than bounty hunting i guess
the theme of this series and boba's
hidden weapon because everyone assumes
boba still needs to learn this lesson
but in reality as we see in the
flashback does he knows way more about
family than all these crooked huts who
were born into their dynasty do back in
the sanctuary cantina the rx series
droid deal some cards is the same kind
of droid as rx24 from star tours and rex
from ogus cantina but sitting around
this table are a shadra fan and then
this dip shed who looks like his
daughter uses a sharpie to draw some
darth maul tattoos on his face boba
chats with garcia whip now you're
sweating like a gumptone mustapha yeah i
guess this is the star wars equivalent
of forgive me but i'm sweating like a
[ __ ] in church gumpta as far as i know
is not a word we've heard in star wars
but yes of course mustafar the volcanic
planet where obi-wan fought anakin and
where vader built his castle and that
castle was built on the grounds of a
sith temple making this a kind of church
for him garcia says that the twins have
claimed jabba's turf despite boba's
assumption that they were partying it up
on hutta referring to nalhatta the
hutt's home world max rebo's band cuts
out as the drums of the hutt's litter
approach and outside the hut twins are
carried in on their litter their immense
weight sagging the platform in the
middle i love how the poor carriers just
look like they're struggling more and
more throughout the scene now these huts
have an aquarium snack bowl like jabba
would often have that male hut has a
cage off to the side containing a rodent
that he later uses to mop up his sweat
based on that rodent's antenna it looks
like the same kind of rodent that was
swallowed up by the wart outside of
jabba's palace and returned the jedi
nearby the gawkers include some jawas
and a hask in a bikini top hot the
hudson veil this massive wookie in
gladiator armor this is black kursantin
a bounty hunter from the 2015 darth
vader comics and the 2016 dr aphra
stories he once worked for jabba
alongside boba fett when they both took
gigs from darth vader meaning these two
have a shared history later on he worked
for the scoundrel archaeologist dr aphra
a badass indiana jones-like figure of
the star wars universe who may now show
up in live action chrysanthean's
backstory was that he was a kashyyyk
outcast who ended up with the slavers
zazanti brothers who injected metal into
his knuckles to make him a fiercer
gladiator and then during his time with
jabba the hutt around the year 10 bby
this is the year before the obi-wan
kenobi series will be set kursantin took
owen lars hostage on tatooine ended up
getting scarred in a battle with ben
kenobi events that we may now see on the
obi-wan kenobi series coming later this
year if you look closely you can see the
slightly pinkish region above the right
eye where obi-wan's lightsaber burned
him and in addition to the metal in his
knuckles chrysanthemum wears some spiked
brass knuckles over his fingers boba
fett scoffs you can bring as many
gladiators as you wish
but these are not the deathbeds of durr
and i am not a sleeping transocean guard
yes durrrr is another new bit of star
wars lore apparently some planet that
hostic gladiator combat and boba is
recalling some memory from chrysanthe's
past where he just got lucky with a
sleeping transition an insult to this
great gladiator and boba's also
insulting all the nearby transitions
that he just passed they're definitely
within earshot after they leave fenix
says
they're huts
we would have to get permission if you
want to kill them permission from whom
these rules cast the hutts as
untouchable crime bosses like captains
in la casa nustra this mysterious boss
of bosses may be kira who was mauls
number two after dryden boss's death and
solo star wars story within that crimson
dawn crime organization which during
clone wars maul created out of the
shadow collective which included the
huts along with the pike syndicate who
we see in this episode and other groups
like the black sun and the death watch
which later became the same watch clan
that the mandalorian din jaren was a
part of now maul of course died in his
rematch with kendrobe
shortly before the new hope events so
kira would now be the head of the
crimson dawn emilia clarke will appear
on another disney plus series secret
invasion so she's already part of the
family she could totally show up in a
star wars series too another flashback
dust shows boba's time with the tuscans
now he's got an intermediary stick
showing he's working his way up that
hierarchy they dig up one of those
creatures i brought up before a wart
that toad-like beast that we saw in
return of the jedi and then we hear this
roar from the horizon
[Music]
now this is the train of the pike
syndicate but this roar sounds a lot
like the sound effect that they use for
the crate dragon
so i'm wondering if the pikes might
blare this sound as a siren to scare off
the tuscans the same way ben kenobi used
the sound of a crate dragon to scare
people away from luke but either way
it's interesting how the tuscans fear
that spike train the same way the people
of moss pogo fear the crate dragon and
this relationship between the pikes and
the tuscans is mirrored directly from
the history of the american west when
the expansion of the transcontinental
railroad was devastating both to the
indigenous tribes and the american bison
which trained travelers would just fire
at from the trains for sport and leave
the carcasses to ride like until now
star wars stories have always cast
tuscans as tuscan raiders and sand
people the other but this series follows
the mandalorian chapter 9 by recasting
the tuscans as sympathetic people with
their own culture their own humanity and
you see this with this pike train
literally firing the first shot
unprovoked killing the bantha afterwards
the tuscans burned their dead on a
funeral pyre evoking jedi funeral pyres
one of the many ways this episode
actually parallels tuscan spirituality
with jedi mysticism boba tracks down
those nekto raiders that we saw in
episode 1 when they attacked the
moisture farm to this toshi station this
is the same location as we saw in the
deleted sequence from the 1977 star wars
when luke met up with biggs the interior
was totally recreated perfectly with
even that same electronic game that they
play in that scene and inside is cammy
mars trap and lay's fixer lonoser these
are luke's friends from that scene you
remember cammy she called him wormy i
love how they even kept the late 70s
hairstyles this is amazing you know i've
been breaking down these kind of things
for years now and to keep me going i
like to have some snacks within reach
the problem is i've just kind of gotten
tired of the same old snacks i've been
curious about mixing up some snacking
with some new flavors and if you're like
me you should give baksu a try thanks to
boxy for sponsoring this video boksu is
a monthly subscription service that
delivers premium japanese snacks and tea
pairings straight from japan to your
door each themed monthly bok su box
takes you on a gourmet journey through
japan baksu is the only company that
partners with 100 year old family snack
makers for genuine and authentic
selections the first box suit you will
receive is called seasons of japan look
it comes loaded with snacks here and
this booklet that walks you through it
all not to brag but i have actually been
to japan and i had an incredible trip
visiting my brother and some of these
snacks are just really taking me back
yay
this is the aomori apple caramel cookie
it's made in the apple growing region of
japan and has a soft and chewy texture
that the japanese call yakoi i'm sure i
mispronouncing it but i'm not miss
enjoying this cookie you don't get these
kind of flavors from snacks in the u.s
the box suit box just makes her a really
cool gift for that anime fan or travel
lover in your life click the link in the
description and use our code rockstars
to get 10 off your subscription now
notice how on the back of these nikto's
vests is aurebesh translating to the
word tatooine and they got a crest that
looks like a skeleton with long arms
reaching down to the sides clutching
some bounty just comes off like a pirate
flag which these guys pretty much are
and you'll notice the back of that crest
is formed by the mirrored l shape that
they mark on the moisture farm it also
marks all their speeder bikes along with
that same skeleton crest it's kind of
like the way biker gangs like the hell's
angels wear clothes marked with what
part of the country they're from so i'm
guessing these guys are just the
tattooing division of whatever this
bigger nikto gang is and one of the
neatos that boba hits has more orabesh
at the bottom of his back translating to
emmett oh they're like jerseys also a
reminder of emmett brown who gets
another interesting sort of homage later
in this episode now as boba toes those
speeder bikes back to the tuscans one of
those bikes has tatooine written in
orabesh again on the side look i'm doing
my best to translate all the orbs i can
this episode because that hollow tablet
was just too out of focus to read and i
feel guilt that you can't trust look at
that this is my district
i'm sorry
[Music]
i love this the tuscans dismantle the
bikes oh stop stop no
no
stop
these are mine
i love that final delay tossed by the
tuscan in the back well it's in my hand
i don't want to hold anymore onto the
amazing train attack which feels so
intense because in the opening throws so
many tuscans go down and you can see how
this weighs on boba in this awesome
over-the-shoulder reaction which makes
him vulnerable to the shot that damages
his engine so now bubba has to totally
shift his objective he pulls the brakes
to grab that falling tuscan and then
swings both of them from the grappling
rope right as the bike explodes this is
just great action filmmaking here and
right as these tuscans are caught in the
crossfire the female warrior notices
that boba's car is now being swarmed
without his knowledge by more pikes
coming in from behind so what does she
do she ramps her bike into that car
behind in order to cork the swarm but
then this alerts that super anxious
conductor droid who directs fuel from
the core that's the orabesh written up
top to the boost that's the orbish
written below like it's freaking doc
brown throwing the yellow fuel log on
this droid is nuts it even has one eye
pointing down like a psycho and then
just uses all four of its hands to crank
up the speed now while the amazing steph
green directed this episode the dp was
better in cinematographer dean cunley
who shot the back to the future train
finale and all three back to the future
films actually shot a lot of movies you
love so this whole train sequence plus
the emmett shout out i feel like that's
intentional enough i love how we get a
terrifying sense of scale for this
increased speed when that female warrior
boards the car and smacks out a pike
yeah great indiana jones style whip
crack punch sound effect there and then
immediately when that pike hits the
ground he zips out of frame so to stop
the train boba has to use his gaffy
stick to pry the lever back using the
traditional tuscan tool to overpower the
far more advanced tech and we should say
this whole train sequence definitely
feels like an homage to lawrence of
arabia a major influence on george
lucas's generation of filmmakers and
also memorably included a train attack
that won this stranger in the strange
land the respect of the local tribes
afterwards boba addresses the pikes who
try to play dumb about spice what do you
mean by spice sensana spice from the
slave mines of castle yes the pike
syndicate runs the spice mines on kessel
we actually saw this in solo when that
pike was still wearing the mask but this
is the first time i think that we have
seen a pike unmasked in live action
using the animated series we saw them
without their masks and now you can see
how beneath these headpieces their
features are actually pretty aquatic
similar in nature at least to the mon
calamari the quarrens which would
explain their fear of dehydration in the
desert and their need to wear masks to
protect them from this atmosphere and
why they had a whole car full of water
but then spice dumps out of the crate
and it glitters in the air and of course
spice is a term for drugs which was one
of the many world details that george
lucas pulled directly from frank
herbert's dune parallels that now seems
super obvious since dennyville news dune
and it depicts this hallucinogenic spice
melange in a very similar way so bova
makes the pikes walk to anchor head
telling them to walk in a single file as
tuscans always do to hide their numbers
the tuscan chieftain later explains
[Music]
according to the ultimate star wars book
tatooine was once covered by vast oceans
in lush rainforest but in current canon
it was dried out through some unknown
means though in earlier legends
literature this was a result of the
rakatans who bombed the hell out of the
planet it's still yet to be known what
caused it in maine star wars canon but
it does seem like whatever happened the
tuscans and the jawas withstood this
climate change just a fascinating bit of
history that redefines these tribes as
true post-apocalyptic survivors and then
the chieftain's got a lizard that crawls
up boba's nose
yeah i love the echo on the chieftain's
final word as boba spirals and has a bad
trip or the best ever trip because he
walks across the dune sea which crashes
up in ocean waves his body is
superimposed with his armor both on and
off and storm clouds thunder behind him
just some brilliant elemental contrast
here the dune sea of dry sand his new
home ebbing into the oceans of kamino
his birthplace and then he finds this
pair of trees on the dune ahead or is it
a wave of water we never see vegetation
on the planet of tatooine but this
elusive gaffy tree must exist somewhere
for him to have gotten his branch and
only the lizard knows where trees are
hugely significant to force mysticism
jedi trees were considered beacons of
force sensitivity carefully cultivated
underneath jedi temples a tree was
actually used to shelter a temple on
nachto when luke lived there this lizard
could actually be considered an
animalistic equivalent to morai the owl
guide for ahsoka tano of course tuscans
are not jedi and they don't at all
subscribe to those dogmatic religious
beliefs but the force is real it's an
energy that surrounds and binds all
living things including the tuscans so
the lizard and these trees could just be
their mystical interpretation of the
same thing and this natural imagery also
evokes luke's deconstructed description
of the force in the last jedi it's the
energy between all things a tension a
balance that binds the universe together
what do you see
the island
life
death and decay that feeds new life
warmth
cold
peace
violence
and notice how in the branches of this
tree we see a number of pairs of red
eyes in the concept art that rolls
during the credits these were meant to
be jawas which is super interesting to
me because jawas alongside tuscans are
the only native sentient beings to this
planet and this tree may represent a
historic peace between these two tribes
perhaps the original tribes of tatooine
of this episode's title one tall tree
one small tree representing the tall
tuscans and the shorter jawas and then
as the branches wrap around him they
cross dissolve into the innards of the
sarlacc which bobo was not unarmored as
he crawled out of last episode so this
reframes that slimy emergence as a
metaphorical birth for his character
it's gross to think about but it is the
most natural thing in the world folks
and throughout this process we get some
awesome super impositions the shot of
boba holding django's helmet newly shot
for the series dissolves into boba's
adult face in that helmet boba as a
child witnesses his father departing
kamino leaving him behind and in that
ship reflection on the window appears on
his cheek in the shape of a teardrop and
then his child hand reaching out to his
father dissolving into the adult hand
reaching up out of the sand and then at
this point boba snaps the branch which
cuts to an explosion of waves
metaphorically snapping the umbilical
cord leashing him to his incubated state
of his biological lineage through django
he is no longer just a django clone he
has his own identity achieved through
the tuscans and so they finally
re-clothed boba from his undergarments
to more traditional tuscan robes with
some awesome music
[Music]
look figuring composed the main themes
of the show but all this music was
actually composed by his colleague
joseph shirley who mixes these deep
vocal chanting to imbue this moment with
sacred reverence the shots of him
getting roped here also mirror his
getting armored up in episode one for
him now his boba fett armor is really an
extension of his tuscan identity they
guide him to carve his branch into a
true ornate gappy stick and what i love
about this process is that the lizard is
no longer in his brain whereas the
location in the retrieval of the branch
was a subconscious ritual its
weaponization must be conscious and done
by his own hand and if you think about
it it's another jedi parallel as a rite
of passage jedi must construct their own
lightsabers using kyber crystals that
they retrieve from the natural world and
this whole armory set was inspired
directly from original art by rock
mcquarrie in 1977 depicting his designs
for the sand people of tatooine i love
how they brought back in that curved
piece of scrap hole so cool yet still
this whole process is not complete until
he returns to the campfire to obtain the
approval of the chieftain and join the
others in the ceremonial dance because
it's not about the lone warrior on a
solo introspective journey is about
coming back from that journey to become
a member of a tribe and joining them in
the dance i love this episode so much i
can't wait to keep breaking down this
series with you so you can support new
rock stars by checking out our merch
options at new rockstarsmerch.com follow
me on instagram and twitter at eavos
follow me rockstar subscribe to
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
boba
[Music]
you